hey everyone I'm Jimmy I'm Zack and I'm
Jas and I'm Sam and today we have our
reactions to the Oscar nominations first
and foremost let's talk about grand
Budapest hotel and Birdman which led
with nine nominations each is that
surprise doodle I'm not surprised really
actually yeah those movies are really
solid but I mean grand Budapest was
released at the beginning of the year I
think we were all overreacting like
people will forget grand Budapest exists
clearly they didn't yet that's pretty
sad yeah but Birdman Birdman is my
favorite film of the year I know I don't
think it's gonna win best picture but I
do think that it really deserves all the
accolades that's gotten up absolutely
you know I repeat Golden Globe I think
Linklater is gonna win for Best Director
yeah be honest and I don't think Ed
Norton will win for Best Supporting ah
yeah I don't think I went for Supporting
Actor either but I do think that Keaton
has a really good chance see I think
Eddie redmayne's a walk for Best Actor
action I think so too I think it'll
definitely win for cinematography
Emmanuel Lubezki is second to none in
terms of photography let's talk about
some of the other other pleasant
surprises one in particular is Princess
Kaguya for Vienna best animated film yes
Princess Kaguya and song of the sea'
which a lot of people haven't seen but
now this will give them a reason to seek
those films out but this also leads to a
controversy which is the lego movie not
nominated which I know a lot of people
are upset about yeah are you guys upset
about that I'm a little disappointed but
also I'm happy to see some other films
sort of you know making making some
headway into to getting out to a bigger
audience yeah it's nice but let's talk
also talk about a whiplash whiplash was
one of my favorite film so you're flying
number two to Birdman sure I was
thrilled to see all the nominations that
it got including Best Picture I'm gonna
call right now and say I think it's
gonna win editing you know what that
means it is gonna be the first Bloom
house movie to win an Oscar that could
be pretty great right yeah another
pleasant surprise for me was EDA
actually professed cinematography which
is a gorgeous black and white film think
all of the categories really got it
right the the notable exception I think
some people will say is where is
Foxcatcher or where is Nightcrawler like
you were saying but
the film though that that definitely is
deserving it was completely absent from
the Golden Globes for some reason was
American sniper which I think really
shows how much people love us women how
good it is but an American sniper still
picked up quite a few Awards it did it
did um but although going back to the
Fox catcher and Nightcrawler
these are pretty dark movies yeah gone
girl is another really dark movie which
I'm gonna bring it up completely snubbed
across the board almost so that's very
interesting not even a debit screenplay
not even nothing that's a little shot I
have been interesting Best Picture snub
guardians of the galaxy the Oscars
expanded the pool to up to ten pictures
if they were gonna include a blockbuster
this was the blockbuster to include
guardians I got he did get a couple yeah
yeah yes technical detective nominations
every year and it's like oh it's just
harder to make them worldwide Willie
yeah it's true the film stands on its
own and people will remember Guardian
sigasi for years now the one thing I am
really hoping to see is Hans number win
for his score winners dollar yeah I saw
it
I kind of was scratching my head a
little bit when I yeah which is also
nominated here and a lot has two scores
I mean he's probably my favorite working
composer today but I still think that
Hans Zimmer scores positive as far as
haunting it's also another snub that I
know Zack and I are pretty passionate
about is Jake Gyllenhaal er yes I I
think that this was like one of the
performances of the year one stub more
than I got a throw absolutely life
itself
Roger Ebert oh yeah from Steve James
directed some of the best documentaries
in the last 25 years and they've never
been not with it the interrupters hoop
dreams yeah it's really ridiculous so
I'm sure he'd saw it coming also really
surprising that wasn't on there is the
overnighters which a lot of people have
been talking about is a fantastic
documentary now really quickly can we
just touch on back in April we did a
video oh do it with yes called premature
amateur Oscar or addiction now the
Oscars were earlier this month but we
Phil we've heard enough of the early
buzz to go ahead and take a stab at
predicting what's gonna win next
now this was before any of these movies
that come out or he'd seen any of them
to be fairies so sure so DJs and most of
trailers haven't come on Jess how did
you fare not terribly well again I feel
this is going to go to unbroken for
Angelina Jolie but then we saw the film
really quick just want to touch on the
foreign language film Danny's force
majeure it's not here at all um
Leviathan I'm incredibly happy about
like we were saying this the big
surprise of the year is weird it really
did even though it's been in the works
for 12 years you know you were saying
they really kept it under wraps it sort
of came out of nowhere
yeah you know and and I think just
completely blew people away same thing
with Birdman like people knew you was
making this movie called Birdman but
from a plot description you hear about a
washed-up superhero character on doing a
Broadway play you sort of scratch your
head at it but then you see it in it
it's all there it really comes together
so it's it's funny I think if this
exercise taught you anything it's to not
judge a film by its logline it's true
guys I learned a lot really quick just a
replica let's not do a long segment
after I say this and we'll just really
quickly wrap up so for figure B quips
I'm Sam I'm Jas I'm Zack and I'm Jimmy
thanks for watching
you